اشتداد المعارك في السودان لليوم الثاني
على التوالي ومصر وجنوب السودان تعريضان
الوساطه لوقف اطلاق النار بعد ثلاث سنوات
بكين تلغي الزاميه وضع الكمامات
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من التطورات الاخيره في السودان الذي
يشهد صراعا مسلحا بين الجيش بقياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده
محمد حمدان الاشتباكات تتواصل اليوم
الثاني في اكثر من منطقه لكنها تتركز
بمحيط مبنى القياده العامه للجيش بالعاصمه
الخرطوم حيث يسعى كل طرف لان يحكم السيطره
عليها بالكامل الجيش اعلن انه سيطر على
مقرات الدعم السريع في سبع ولايات فيما
سقط نحو 60 مدنيا جراء تلك الاشتباكات حتى
الان قبل اعلان الجانبين لاستجابه لمبادره
امميه لفتح مسارات امنه
وفي محاوله لوقف اطلاق النار عرضت كل من
مصر وجنوب السودان الوساطه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ووفقا لبيان
الرئاسه المصريه فقد ناشدت جارتا السودان
لاطراف المتنازعه تغلب صوت الحكمه واللجوء
الى الحوار السلمي وذلك خلال اتصال هاتفي
بين الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
ورئيس جنوب السودان سلفا كرم قبل ذلك
استمرت الادانات الدوليه لما يجري بين
البرهان وحينيتي وطلبت كل من موسكو وروما
وواشنطن ولندن السودانيه بضروره وقف
القتال واللجوء الى طاوله المفاوضات
ومن اخبار السودان نذهب الى الصين بعد نحو
ثلاث سنوات على قرار الزامها اعلنت اداره
مترو الانفاق في بكين الغاء الزام الركاب
بوضع الكمامات مؤكده ان فيروس كورونا لم
يعد خطيرا على البشر وبعد القرار بدقائق
بدا موظفوه المترو بازاله اللافتات التي
تذكر الناس بوضع الكمامات سبق ذلك تصريح
لسلطات النقل في الصين وصفت فيها سنوات
كورونا بالحقبه التي ولت
وبالتزامن مع ذلك استبعد اطباء ان تتعرض
الصين لموجه كبيره اخرى من الاصابات على
مستوى البلاد
للبحث عن حياه وعالم جديدين اطلقت وكاله
الفضاء الاوروبيه مركبه اي اس اي فضائيه
اطلق عليها اسم مستكشفه اقمار المشتري
الجليديه او جوس حيث ستقضي المركبه
الفضائيه نحو ثلاث سنوات ونصف في دراسه
كوكب المشتري وثلاثه من اكبر اقماره متحدث
باسم الوكاله الاوروبيه قال في مؤتمر صحفي
ان الهدف من هذه الرحله هو فهم ما اذا
كانت هناك بيئات صالحه للسكن بين تلك
الاقمار الجليديه وحول كوكب عملاق مثل
المشتري لكن الامر قد يستغرق سنوات لمعرفه
ذلك
نختم اخبارنا من البرازيل فلول مره استخدم
الاطباء جلد سمكه البلطي الاستوائيه في
علاج الحروق الشديده التجربه الاولى كانت
من نصيب امراه برازيليه اصيبت بحروق من
الدرجه الثانيه نتيجه تعرضها لحادث انفجار
عبوه غاز فيما اكدت المريضه نجاح هذا
العلاج الذي انتهى بشفائها من الحروق
معلقه انها ستوصي كل مصاب بها وعن سبب
اعتماد هذا العلاج اكد الاطباء ان جلد سمك
البلطي يحتوي على مستويات عاليه من
الرطوبه والكولاجين